[Music]
volkswagen is back in the World Rally
championships again after many years and
it seems they may even drive off with
the top prize
with this VW Polo R WRC normal drivers
can feel like they're in the race to
these tests or two-letter test drivers
magic nap is showing us the street
version of the Polo R WRC and it's just
as important as the rally car itself
WRC rules stipulate that 30,000 cars of
a type need to be sold before a racing
version can be built and to use the
racing version in a rally you need a
similar version to proof for the street
you'd end up failing this car that is
the result
it's the VW polo RWC Tata horse in the
year 162 kilowatts of power 350 lays the
meters of torque it's a little bit
gentler than the rally car but it's
still not plenty on you can ignore and
there and sports follows Auto so first
you get the street vehicle then the
rally car another interesting detail is
that Volkswagen designers draft the GTI
and our models first then they base
designs for the standard street car on
those to ensure mass-market appeal
you
up until now VW s biggest rally success
came at the rally World Championship in
1986 the car was a near Series golf 2
GTI Kenneth Erickson and Peter Hickman
were the winning drivers
[Music]
but let's get back to the present and
the VW Polo R WRC in gigging zat's oil
it's a chances that unlike the rally
versions 1.6 liter engine the street car
has a 2-liter four-cylinder gasoline
engine that will rocket it to 100 in 6.4
seconds
it doesn't crank out the 232 kilowatts
that the rally polo does but it's more
powerful than the GTI but the top speed
of 243 km/h calm heart is lost an
incredible 350 Newton meters of torque
puts it 100 Newton meters ahead of the
Polo GTI meaning it's one second faster
in the sprint
nevertheless the Radek are still leaves
the street polo in the dust it can bang
up to 100 in 3.9 seconds but when it
comes to top speed the street version
surpasses the rally car by 43 km/h
[Music]
to be honest for sure it's a lot of
differences because one is made
completely for the race and one is for
the normal road for every day but I try
quickly this one and this one is also
really powerful car 220 polos and such a
small polo is a you feel that it's work
quite well and for the rest for sure the
chassis is much better on my race car
because much more precise and more
reactive but that's that's really made
for race and the differences don't stop
there you can see the two polos are
worlds apart the engine drivetrain
chassis and much more were changed to
make the rally car there's good reason
for that
mechanics need to be able to change a
transmission in minutes or overhaul the
entire car in just four hours
the similarity between the two is kind
of hard to see under the racing decals
[Music]
[Music]
what they do share is bodywork they have
similar doors hood and hatch
[Music]
the number on the rear spoiler tells you
which vehicle you're looking at and that
it's part of a limited edition of 2500
units a basic coat of white paint with
blue green stripes and rally style
bumpers give the street color a track
field a special sports chassis brings
the body closer to the road and includes
stability in turns it's time to go
racing in the streets
[Music]
[Music]
looking at the interior the
multifunction sports steering wheel
stands out the feel of the black
Alcantara leather makes drivers no until
it go the bucket seats of rally style
and driver and passenger where they
belong the center console is done in
gray our Katara
it's easy to use as usual combines front
with function mia Dauphine finished
laughter New Zealand artist driver says
he loved testing the street version of
the VW Polo R WRC in Finland back money
is a consideration too it's not exactly
a bargain at thirty three thousand nine
hundred euros and you've got to be
really lucky to pick up one of the 2,500
units in the Edition where after winning
the finish event the ninth of 13 world
championship races in the series it
looked as if VW and their driver
Sebastien Ogier were almost a shoo-in
but they're not there yet the next
attempt he and his Poehler will make for
the ronny ground is in australia
[Music]
you